let's put on your wise
sage hat and ask you what advice would
you give to young people today in high
school and college
about life about how to live a
successful life
in career or just in general that they
can be proud of
most young people when they actually ask
you that question what they usually mean
is how can i be successful by usual
standards yeah i'm not very good at
giving advice about that because that's
not how i tried to live my life
um
so i would more flip it around and say
you live in a rich society
you will have a long life you have many
resources available to you
whatever career you take you'll have
plenty of time to make progress on
something else
yes it might be better if you find a way
to to combine your career and your
interests in a way that gives you more
time and energy but there are often big
compromises there as well
so if you have a passion about some
topic or something that you think just
was worth pursuing you can just do it
you don't need other people's approval
and you can just start doing whatever it
is you think
is worth doing it might take you decades
but decades are enough to make enormous
progress on most all interesting things
and don't worry about the commitment of
it i mean that's a lot of what people
worry about is
well there's so many options and if i
choose a thing and i stick with it you
know i sacrifice all the other paths i
could have taken but i mean so i
switched my career at the age of 34 with
two kids age zero and two went back to
grad school and social science after
being a software
research software
engineer
so it's quite possible to change your
mind later in life
um how can you have an age of zero
less than one
okay
so
oh oh you index was there yeah i got it
okay right you know like people also ask
what to read and i say textbooks
and until you've read lots of textbooks
or maybe review articles i'm not so sure
you should be reading you know
blog posts and and uh twitter feeds and
even podcasts i would say
at the beginning read the read you know
this is our best sum humanity's best
summary of how to learn things is
crammed into textbooks especially the
the ones on like introduction to
everything introduction to everything
just read all the algorithms
read as many textbooks as you can
stomach and then maybe if you want to
know more about a subject find review
articles
you don't need to read the latest stuff
from most topics yeah and actually
textbooks often have the the prettiest
pictures there you go and then depending
on the field if it's technical then
doing the homework problems at the end
yeah it's actually extremely extremely
useful
extremely powerful way to understand
something if you allow it you know i
actually think of like high school and
college
which you you kind of remind me of
people don't often think of it that way
but
you'll almost
not again get an opportunity
to spend the time with the fundamental
stuff
and like all the basics and everybody's
forcing you like everybody wants you to
do it
and like you'll never get that chance
again to sit there
even though it's outside of your
interest biology like in high school i
took ap biology ap chemistry
um
i'm thinking of subjects i never again
really visited seriously and it was so
nice to be forced into uh anatomy and
physiology
to be forced into that world
to stay with it to look at the pretty
pictures to certain moments to actually
for a moment enjoy the beauty of these
of like how cell works and all those
kinds of things and your somehow that
stays like the ripples of that
fascination that stays with you even if
you never do those this if even if you
never
utilize those uh
learnings in your actual world a common
problem at least many young people i
meet is that they're like feeling
idealistic and altruistic but in a rush
yes so
you know the usual human tradition that
goes back you know hundreds of thousands
of years is that people's productivity
rises with time and maybe peaks around
the age of 40 or 50.
the age of 40 50 is when you will be
having the highest income you'll have
the most contacts you will sort of be
wise about how the world works
expect to have your biggest impact then
before then
you are you can have impacts but you're
also mainly building up your resources
and abilities
um that's that's the usual human
trajectory expect that to be true of you
too don't be in such a rush to like
accomplish enormous things at the age of
18 or whatever i mean you might as well
practice trying to do things but
that's mostly about learning how to do
things by practicing there's a lot of
things you can't do unless you just keep
trying them
and uh when all else fails try to
maximize the number of offspring however
away you can that's certainly something
i've neglected i i would tell my younger
version of myself hey try to have more
descendants
yes absolutely it matters more than i
gave i realized at the time
both in terms of
making copies of yourself in in mutated
form
and
just the joy of raising them sure i mean
the meaning even
you know
so
in the literature on
the value people get out of life there's
a key distinction between happiness and
meaning so happiness is how do you feel
right now about right now
and meaning is how do you feel about
your whole life
and you know many things that produce
happiness don't produce meaning as
reliably and if you have to choose
between them you'd rather have
meaning and
meaning is
more goes along with sacrificing
happiness sometimes
and children are an example of that do
you get a lot more meaning out of
children even if they're a lot more work
you